EU health ministers have been studying
plans to revise laws on medical devices
the talks in Luxembourg the ministers
were updated on draft rules for things
like corrective classes dental filling
material x-ray machines heart valves or
breast implants and on in vitro
diagnostic devices such as blood tests
the aim is to define a framework for
production and market circulation of
medical devices restoring trust among
consumers users and stakeholders while
ensuring a high level of protection for
health the council also looked at
nutrition and physical activity given
that up to seven percent of EU health
budgets are directly spent each year on
disease linked to obesity The ministers
express concern at the scale of the
obesity problem they invited you
countries in the European Commission to
better inform citizens about the
benefits of physical activity and a
healthy diet in other items on the
agenda ministers responsible for
employment and Social Policy looked at
the representation of women on company
boards the European Commission wants to
increase the number of women on non
executive boards to forty percent by
2020 EU nations support the principle of
improving the gender balance although
some nations believe this should be done
at the national level while others
prefer eu-wide legislation